If you're familiar with the flask
web development framework,
you should be no stranger
to the app.route decorator.
This decorator in flask can be used
to make URLs to render webpages and
API endpoints alike.
You should also import
the jsonify package from
flask into your application.
Jsonify can convert dictionaries
into JSON objects that can then be
sent to the client.
The jsonify function in flask
returns the flask response object
that already has the appropriate content
type header for use with JSON responses.
In this next exercise,
you'll familiarize yourself with
making basic API endpoints with flask.